what's happening in the food world is
that chefs and diners are demanding a
greater variety and less oversight and
our regulatory system is not set up for
that hi I'm Alexis Garcia with Reason TV
and today I'm joined by Dana Goodyear
Dana is a staff writer at The New Yorker
and author of the book anything that
moves
renegade chefs fearless eaters and the
making of new American food culture and
you know I'm really excited to talk to
you because one it's about food and you
know it's kind of been an interesting
intersection here in American food
culture because we're becoming more
adventurous eaters but it seems like the
regulatory establishment can't really
keep up with that yeah we are heading
toward a clash and a lot of people would
say that it's already happening you have
raw milk activists who are very
explicitly at odds with government
regulators and government agencies and
the what's happening in the food world
is that chefs and diners are demanding a
greater variety and less oversight and
the things that are kind of coming from
underground sources or don't have the
same kind of regulatory oversight have
that quality of sort of exciting sexy
new and it's likely illicit and in some
cases and our regulatory system is not
set up for that it's not set up for
artisanal it's there there there are
places where you can see accommodations
being made to this new food movement
like the cottage food laws that are
popping up all over the country but in
general the federal laws really can't
handle this homemade artisanal kind of
slightly underground aspect of food
culture now and I think that a lot of
diners a lot of Americans would be
surprised at how much of the fine dining
scene in this country chefs that they
have heard of who our boldface named
type of chefs are really engaging with
this you know slightly gray market
economy of food you're seeing on menus
now that chefs are using dirt they're
using ash I imagine that the FDA didn't
really envision that there you think
yeah they're using ingredients and
techniques that often aren't even
contemplated and they're sort of staying
one step ahead of the regulations but
these moments of conflict or crisis you
know tonka beans a few years ago became
you know a lot of chefs too had no idea
that tonka beans have been on the FDA
not approved list since the 1950s
because of an ingredient in it as an
anticoagulant and there was a concern
that it could cause hemorrhaging tonka
bean is an ingredient sort of tastes
like vanilla and it's used widely in
pastries and ice creams in Europe and
chefs here like grant a cat's very well
known chef three Michelin stars and
first restaurant Alinea in Chicago
we're using it and had no idea and then
there's spice cabinets we're being
raided by the FDA and it was that was
that was now several years ago but there
are things like this occur frequently
and raw milk is another one another
flashpoint you actually talked about raw
milk and a store here in Venice called
Rossum and their whole motto was we're
not gonna sell it to you unless it's
dangerous but what's interesting is that
there's a complete inversion of the idea
of what's safe and what's dangerous and
in that community which is a very
extreme community where I wanted to look
at it the idea was you know anything
that the government has come within a
mile of is dangerous that means that
it's been sprayed with you know
antibacterials you know the that it has
been chemically treated in ways that
that community is not comfortable with
and feels is unsafe and unhealthy for
them and so the government idea of safe
food and and often the foodie idea of
safe food is completely inverted you
know it seemed like you were a little
bit skeptical which may be a good thing
because you know I don't want to eat
something that could potentially kill me
I personally don't take it to the
extreme of you know demanding that I be
allowed to eat food that's contaminated
with Listeria
I don't want listeriosis but there's a
role in my mind there's a significant
role for regulation in food the
situation that our regulatory bodies
were set up to address a hundred plus
years ago was a complete Wild West of
food and people had no idea what was in
the can and what was in the label was
not what was in the can and it was
obvious people were getting sick
children were dying something had to be
done but the way in which that initial
legislation the Pure Food and Drugs Act
of 1906 has been built upon has really
encouraged the industrialization of
and it's really only possible for very
large producers to comply perfectly and
and it creates other problems like some
of the worst food contamination issues
of the last several years the cantaloupe
where many people died of Listeria that
was a situation where's a large-scale
producer and a lot of people now are
feeling that smaller scale producers who
may not be able to afford the manpower
to keep up with the paperwork that's
required for compliance actually are
practicing you know they're practicing
safe food they are they are doing things
properly because it's on a smaller scale
but the problem is just how do you
guarantee that you trace the rise of
this whole underground supperclub
movement which has really become
fashionable especially here in Los
Angeles do you see that movement growing
nationwide yeah I think a lot of it
comes out of LA which is why as somebody
who lives in LA I wanted to write this
book in 2008 we've had a economic crisis
and one of the things that came out of
it was a sort of shift in how the
restaurant business works the the four
walls of the restaurant came down and
Ludo Lefebvre see everywhere now all the
time he said you know I I don't want to
get investors and you know do if several
million dollar build-out for a
restaurant and then have to serve
everything to everyone in order to be
able to make that rent and pay for the
space I want to do a really specific
menu of my stuff it'll attract a
pre-selected group of diners who already
are into that kind of thing and are
willing to take risks and are willing to
be delighted and maybe not love
everything and not be able to get the
steak frite and he did these pop-ups and
then that became a widely copied model
and and then the underground chefs are
able to use like bulls mouth he's very
careful and does everything the right
way but there are tons of them out there
and they're using ingredients that are
not necessarily FDA approved and they
can because they're not actually selling
and they believe they can because
they're not selling the food it's often
a donation and you know it's a question
whether that legal loophole will stand I
think a lot of people are waiting to
find out and waiting to see how serious
the local public health department's are
about cracking down on it but it's also
true that it's a great booming business
if you're paying your taxes which some
of them are then does government really
want to stamp that out these are
entrepreneurs and they are creating
opportunities for tourism and they're
they're adding to the cultural life of
the cities that they were operating in
so I think it's a delicate thing I think
they're discovering that there are ways
of being in business that are not the
traditional ways of being in business
you went to a weed party where a
cannabis was used as an ingredient in
food and first of all was it any good I
had to be a little careful because I'm a
nerd and I was pregnant so I was not
being as Hardy and eater as I might have
been under other circumstances but what
I tried was all delicious and I did a
sort of taste and spit you know I didn't
inhale there were lots of dishes there
that were not did not use the cannabis
but used a lot of Chinese medicinal
herbs which I also had to be careful
about because those that's strong
medicine - that was a really fun dinner
because it really got right to the heart
of first of all chefs innovating and
experimenting and using ingredients that
are not typically thought of as food
ingredients in our culture but have
historically been food ingredients I
mean the Romans used cannabis as part of
a dessert and there is precedent for it
but we're just it's so endure from
unfamiliar to us and then here it is an
ingredient that is actually a Schedule
one drug and it you know the DEA could
have busted that dinner and so it had
all these elements that were interesting
to me and then the dining population is
interesting to me you know the people
who are willing to take these risks who
are willing to take legal risks to eat
the food that they want to eat and I
think that that's a really new thing in
this country that there are people who
are activists around access to food and
ingredients and food experiences so it
was it was incredibly fun and it also
just it seemed to me to be so of the
moment and of course it was happening in
LA with LA chefs who are I think really
pushing the boundaries of what's
considered edible well it's very
interesting and thank you so much for
joining us today thank you is a great
pleasure and for a reason TV I'm
sis Garcia